foreign
and it's joint work together here with
Nikolai who is in the audience
and I will talk about mcsat-based
approaches for solving non-linear
modular arithmetic
so what is the typical problem that we
want to solve
so we have given a set of polynomial
equations and also this equalities
um they are non-linear so we see that
here we have an x squared we have a
monomials with x times y
and we want to solve the solution system
over a finite domain so in this case in
this example I want to solve it over the
finite field
F5 so we take the solutions modulo 5 and
I want to solve this polynomial system
now with you because I will use it
throughout the talks this will be kind
of our running example so I really want
to familiarize you with that
yeah since we're talking about modulo 5
it's actually we can write down the
multiplication table so that we cannot
really work with that
so how would I solve that so the first
uh polynomial is univari we have only
one variable in it x squared and then we
check our multiplication table uh for
which cases x squared is equal to one
and we see we have here two cases first
one is for one and the second is one for
the value is is for the value of four
and let's take let's take the first one
let's say we fix X is equal to one
and then we pack something into the
second polynomial
and then we see that we actually get now
so the second polynomial evaluates now
to Y minus y minus 1 is equal to zero
which actually gives us minus one is
equal to zero so we have a contract
there
we kind of move back we see our choice
for X was wrong so let's maybe try it on
the other one let's set X is equal to
four
we packed it again into the second
solution and this is the second
constraint and then we get we can solve
that if we see that indeed uh
we have to set Y is equal to two
and with both of these values can then
be plugged into the third constraint and
even that is fulfilled so we see we have
a solution for our polynomial system
which is x equal to 4 and y equal to y
um
yes in general solving polynomial
equations is one of the oldest and
hardest problems in mathematics so
there's been quite a lot of verify
mathematicians really for a long period
of time to solve these questions
efficiently
and in the case the domain that we
considered for our polynomial equations
is an algebraic closed field then this
problem is actually decidable and we can
do that by using a group analysis for
net
unfortunately finite domains are not
algebraically closed you cannot throw
burner bases directly on it
um
yeah so today I talk about release
finite domains and the reason why we are
currently interested is is because
linear non-linear polynomial reasoning
over these finite domains is currently
of interest in in formally verifying
group to systems especially when we talk
about finite Fields so the one example
that we had this is for example used to
model serial knowledge proofs or also an
electric uh cryptography and the second
uh domain that I also will consider in
the talk is actually over when we take
modulo 2 to the power of K since
actually we have bit back to solving
that's for example
foreign
so as I said a lot of work has been done
on solving uh polynomial constraints and
until recently uh like this was really
the domain of mathematicians and more
precisely this was the domain of
computer and a lot of so there have been
algorithms devolved like as I said
Revenue basis so they are really
powerful tools and algorithms they are
implemented in powerful tools in the
computer systems like Mathematica
singular sage and so on
this algorithms are powerfully finding
all solutions of a polynomial equation
system
um but they have a downside so usually
this algorithms have a high
computational overheads so for example
government basis algorithms are actually
double exponential
um
to compute
and
in general
we for our use case we are typically not
interested in finding all solutions of
the system actually we want to find only
one solution or we want to know whether
there is no solution at all
this is why we take a look
for why we kind of use the concept of
model constructing satisfiability or
mcsat for short this was invented around
10 years ago
and this approach allows me to find
satisfiber instances of polynomial
arithmetic by combining a cdcl style
search with some Theory knowledge
through some Theory propagation in our
cases will be a surprise decompositions
just
and today I already hinted it a little
bit I will talk about two domains
so the first part of the talk I will
focus on constraints over finite Fields
as I already hinted it's not I should
probably close so it's kind of Applied a
criminal basis directly and the
constraints we consider in this case are
actually equality and disequality the
reason is that that infinite fields that
you cannot totally order the elements so
it doesn't make sense to write down
inequalities
um this is the project
um we call it ffsat and the tool that we
have there is kind of a
a pro we have just a prototype there
let's see
and the second part will be the
constraints over to the power of K so
the speed Vector reasoning
and actually this domain is not even a
field so it's a finite commutative ring
and I will explain later why this
actually makes things more complicated
but here we can consider more
constraints we also now we'll talk about
um inequalities in an addition and also
uh we manually introduce now the
overflows of the final domain and here
our project is called uh purisat
and polysat is invited in implemented as
a theory solver in set three
sorry
um so the question is what is an
inequality modulo 2 to the power of K so
actually we restrict here really the
solutions two to power of KB do not
consider the Overflow so we say we have
a finite domain We compare our numbers
one two two to the K and when we have an
overflow We additionally add constraints
foreign
um but before I go into the domains let
me uh briefly introduce the concept of
the framework of mcsuck to you as I
already said this is an abstract cdcl
decision procession we have heard about
cdcl a couple of times already this week
and in addition to the Boolean search
engine we integrate reasoning over the
theory behind it so in our case of
definite domains
in this framework it allows us to
incrementally construct the models while
searching
and to propagate the literals all our
decisions are Justified model
assignments
and so far so there have been a couple
of theories already
implemented in This MC sub framework so
for example for non-linear arithmetic
constraints of the reals of also foreign
constraints and also there has already
been a little bit of some work on bit
vectors
and the idea the basic idea is that from
a given set of Clauses we generate a
trail with the decided and propagate the
literals in addition to the theory
memorable assignments
then leads to one of the two terminal
States answered or set
and just as a note here when uh we
consider our input as a polynomial
system so it's a system of polynomial
iterations then actually this equation
so each equation is can actually be seen
as a unit clause
so the main components then of this
framework are of course the trail where
we record all the assignments and the
reasons
and for each variable in our polynomial
system to keep track of the viable
values um so these are the values that
can be assigned
at some point we might reach conflict so
there's a set of con of constraints that
will contradict our Trail and then we do
some conflict analysis where we learn a
new constraint with respect to our
Theory to avoid the same that we avoid
the way that we reach the same conflict
in the future
um yeah for us our Trail has a kind of a
special shape
um so what we do is we
when we talk about variance X1 to xn we
consider them ordered so X1 is smaller
to xn and then also our Trail kind of
will be ordered namely in such a way
that when a literal so use F1 G1 HL
enters the trail that actually all
variables in this literal on this
constraint have been assigned except for
the largest one
so this means at first we have kind of
the univariate polynomial constraints uh
over X1 then we make the variable
assignment uh for X1 and then the second
one we can then
this constraint can then talk over X1
and X2 and continue like that and this
guarantees us that all of these are kind
of then
univariate
um
yeah
we can put literals on a trail
first with a kind of regular Boolean
propagation then we have a cross for
example C1 and we see that the first two
literals uh are are already in our Trail
in the negated form then of course we
know that we have to put third
on the trade
and then this Clause will be also be our
justification why we put X on the tray
and in addition to that mcsat allows us
to propagate the theory
maybe from the series from all the
previous variable assignments we know
that a certain literal Edge cannot hold
on a trail
then we know that we can put not the
negation of the constraint on the trail
and the per and what we now have to do
is to generate an explanation Clause
that justifies this decision
influence
um yeah I will do now an example of it
for you this was our example of the of
the first slides of it it's here again
but I've now considered only the first
uh two constraints because the third one
didn't have any friends
so we see the first constraint this
universe so I put it on the trail
um as we have already seen possible
values are x equal to 1 or x equal to
four
let's make the assumption that do the
same
um
uh decision as before but then now set
as X is equal to one
then our second constraints becomes
univariate with respect to this partial
assignment
I put it on the trail and then I reached
the conflict
and so from this conflict then I do the
backtracking and then I generate an
explanation class
written it down here just really just
throw it at you this explanation close
um actually says that we shouldn't set x
equal to one
and so to satisfy the second constraint
we now resolve using the explanation
clause and backtrack to assign a
different value of things
um so and that's actually the key
ingredient that we have uh that we need
to have in our uh mcsat framework namely
uh how do we generate
this explanation clause for our Theory
um
yeah and now so let's go into the theory
part so at first I will talk about the
final field case
um yeah so as usual so field is really
is a set of elements that is closed
under uh addition uh subtraction
multiplication and for each element we
have an inverse and finite field is
means simply we have only a finite
amount of elements in in our field
and now we want to generate an
explanation Clause an explanation
function for that
so the general idea
this is
have some very uh variable assignment up
to K minus one then we have some
literals on it this talk now over
various X1 to x k and up to that point
we are fine this means
we have still the possibility to assign
a value to escape such that all these
literals are true
but now
we want to add another constraint uh t
on the trail
and now such an ex Alpha case or certain
assignment to the variable XK doesn't
exist anymore
now we have the conflict and we need to
resolve these context we need to learn
that we have need to take a different
assignment for variables X1 to x k minus
for
and the idea that you have is we take
all this the constraints that we have on
the trailer speak over XK plus the one
that gives us the conflict
and in all these constraints we
eliminate now the variable x k so we
generate a polynomial set over the
variables X1 to x k minus one
and we put it in such a way on our trade
in the future all the assignments for
this generated set of polynomials gives
us false because this ensures that we do
not run into the same conflict again
um and this will then be how we generate
our elimination process so we include
this generated set of polynomials
um to get a fluid together with the
other uh constraints to to get their
explanations
yeah so I
speak here about let's do some variable
elimination
and this actually means that from a
polynomial uh system we kind of need to
project the solutions
um over the variables X1 to XK into the
uh into a different field where we have
only variable X1 to x k minus one and I
always like to represent this actually
graphically
so think of that like our original
polynomial system
uh space would be talk about variables
like in the three dimensions so x y and
set and we want to now get rid of the
set variable this means we project
um the solutions of of the curve here uh
down into the dimension where set is
equal to zero so down into the to this
plane here so the X Y plane and uh this
would actually mean that kind of you put
a piece of paper in the X Y plane we use
a flashlight Shine from it on above and
then kind of the Shadow will be our
protection this is a projection this is
in our case the unit circle
and that's what we want to do uh with
this variable elimination
and now we have two kind of two two
possibilities
um so the first one is we have a tray
and then already the first or like a
single uh new constraints is already
incompatible so we get already a
conflict from a single uh
um constraint you see this is again our
example that we've seen now multiple
times
because we have the first constraint is
at X to one and then we have the new
constraints and we saw that this is
equivalent
and what we then do
is we take a look
at this polynomial here so the first
part the left side of the equation
and we write it down a little bit
differently namely we write it down now
as a universe polynomial in in y so the
coefficient of Y is not x minus one
and what we do
is for the future we want to exude all
assignments with the same coefficient
evaluation
so the
in our case for our current assignment x
minus 1 evaluates to zero so we want to
exclude all future coefficients where x
minus 1 minus 0 should be unequal to
zero and this is now a little bit too
much for the small example but in
general
this would look like that so we have so
we have a new constraint we write it
down in terms of the variable that we
want to eliminate then we evaluate all
the uh the coefficients so these
polynomials in X1 to x k minus 1 and we
exclude these polynomials minus
um
assignment from our
so from
it's in the future
and this actually
ensures that we exclude the current
assignment of a thing of a single
um polynomial constraints so it's
it's fine but it's not really doing much
so it includes it excludes at least the
current assignment that violates a
single constraint but actually when we
have more constraints
what what do we do then so we do not
want to check kind of iteratively
um to this coefficient based exclusion
overall thing
um
constraints we want to find more General
approach
one way to do it would be to use the
theory of regular basis
because when you have equivalent basis
with a lexicographically cam ordering
then this has the projection property
what we could do
we introduce fresh variables to get uh
rid of all the inequalities
then we have only a set of equalities
because grammar bases only talk of uh
talk about equalities but as I said in
the beginning group replaces require an
algebraically closed field
we don't have this means that usually
when when the
criminal basis algorithm would solve
this polynomial system we kind of need
to tell it which Solutions are
interesting for us and we do this by
adding so-called field polynomials
and then we generate the K minus one
elimination idea Theory this would sound
nice
but I already said in the beginning also
said in the beginning the criminal bases
are a double exponential and especially
these field polynomials they cause a lot
of overhead during this reduction
especially when certain assignments are
already excluded because then suddenly
you don't have here this nice structure
but you really expanded and it gets
messy so that's one way that we do not
want to do it
instead
what we want to do is we have a look at
the polynomials and we exclude common
factors of these polynomials
and especially when we have this uh
um conflict all these polynomials are
univariate
so we do not have to talk about this
whole elimination field instead we have
we can deal with Universe polynomials
and we want to execute common
irreducible factors of that
and I'm bringing another algebraic
concept onto you it's called support and
regular subjects
I'm not going into the details here so
don't worry
but in general what it does is it allows
me to compute the gcd of two polynomials
when I have already a partial assignment
in the take into account this partial
assignment
you can think of it a really writing
quotation mark because it's somehow
related but not really but if you're
familiar if you know euclidean division
algorithm that's kind of the same
procedure that we do here in euclidean
division algorithm with respect to our
current assignment
and I will show you an example to at
least show you what what's what's
happening
so assume now we have two polynomial
constraints f and g so the one is equal
to zero the second one is in equal to
zero constraints
uh we have our current assignment on the
trail is X is equal to three Y is equal
to one
NBC so when we practice in and solve for
the reference here in Cooperative with
our current Trail
because for f to be true set should be
equal to two
if we set set equal to 2 and T then the
constraint is wrong
so what we do now is we compute now this
is a sub result and regular sub chain of
f and g
um magically this gives us this
polynomials
and what we see actually here is that
the second polynomial doesn't contain
set anymore it only talks about X and Y
and that's what we want
because this is not our projected
um
polynomial so we learn now that we
should falsify this polynomial
and when we plug in Solutions we see
that in addition to the current
assignment that we have to trade we can
even exclude now more assignments
yeah so that's actually how our tool or
our python prototype is currently
implemented we iteratively put so we put
the literals on the trail if you find
this a conflict with one polynomial then
we do this coefficient based
um
um protection if we have more
polynomials that cause us a conflict
then we should do this reduction with
this protection with the sub-presultant
regular subjects
compared our approach so far with really
discriminant basis algorithm and so the
grafted benchmarks here are crafting
saturated they have a lot of solutions
all of them a satisfiber for the
randomly really take random variables so
Q is the number of uh
uh is the field size n is the number of
variables C is the number of constraints
and
we see that especially for this random
uh benchmarks we are comparable with uh
we can compare uh with grimner bases
algorithms
but actually now the workforce is really
to to make this uh scalable so
especially here in minbin we have a
field size of 211.
um we can only do kind of a few
variables and then a few uh constraints
yet
so we that's now our current uh task to
really optimize it to make the scalable
yeah so this was the first part
um of my talk are there any questions
for this part
thanks
um hi
um in the explanation function
um what is specific to the fact that you
are in a in a prime field I mean in the
previous slides a lot of what you
presented sounded looked like it could
be applied to
um wherever you can apply those groups
on bases or all the variants that you
have if you're not algebraically closed
like where is the moment in that
explanation where you're actually doing
the module or the Overflow so in kind of
in grouper basis so here this would be
the field polynomials
so there we restrict uh to to this
module and also here this is kind of
hidden here so I didn't include it but
also here in the sub result in regular
sub chains uh the the modulu is included
in this in this computation of the of
the SRS that that did not show you
uh how
how difficult is it is the computation
of the SRS
um so for the problems that we consider
so far it's it's uh it's not that hard
so we use Sage as an underlying system
uh to to compute it
um
uh so there we are we are uh
uh we're pretty efficient but I have
actually I have no idea about kind of
proof complexity wise what what would be
the class yeah I mean how does it grow
once how does the difficulty grow with
so the uh
the polynomials you mean these are these
they stay small so this day and now we
really see kind of no real explosion of
the polynomials uh
um so the first one which was the most
simplest one making the coefficient uh
equals zero yes uh
is it removing just one point or more
than one point
most of the time just one
okay so you mean
let me show you this example this is
really an easy example
um actually it can remove more uh when
when our polynomial so this constraints
is more complex and this polynomial
coefficient has more than one solution
in the finite field then it then it can
remove more too yes right so the other
part is like uh to make it more
practical we need to have tricks of
checking which
values we can pick yes so I I think uh
what I would really now like to
investigate is variable ordering
okay no I I and I meant the values not
the which variables to assign like if
you have a variable X
and what are the feasible values
because let's say you you removed one
point how do you like make it compact
you don't want to store it like
in a list that these values are
yeah so that's actually what we kind of
do in our in the second part
it's a police out yeah we store this
intervals
okay
so um a question actually on slide 15
which is I think two ahead
you you made some comment really quickly
I think I I missed it which is saying
that
um these field polynomials in the
context where some values have already
been excluded
have like a much less attractable
representation
I remember that comment writing your
elaborate on it
yeah so so what I meant with that is so
this would tell us like uh X is equal
for example in X in in when the final
Field modulu Five this polynomial then
tells us I can take values 0 1 2 3 4.
but what what's the case when I already
knew that I cannot assign four
so your thought is in that situation you
would actually build a different a
different so-called field polynomial and
it would okay it's just like then I I I
would divide this polynomial by x minus
four for example and then kind of I need
to expand this x times x minus 1 times x
minus 2 times x minus three this would
then be my new field polynomial gotcha
and your thought is to do that
explicitly or you're saying that's what
happens implicitly inside the governor
basis engine so we saw like so
um I mean you know our previous tracks
and previously we've worked with the
Scribner basis India we actually saw
that what's happening inside our solver
is is that this expansion happened and
then it got stuck got you and then
actually I had a question about the
table that you showed us as well I was
just trying to understand what the
columns are
variable ordering and this is Criminal
basis with respect to a degree reverse
lexical graphic ordering
and what you see here is that kind of
with a degree based uh Revenue bases are
actually better than the
lexicographically but from the
lexicographically they have the the
projection properties this is kind of
the case where we can read off the
solutions from the government basis you
usually cannot do this with a degree
based gotcha so those are like pure
groin basis that's not mcsat with a
cursive basis yes sorry so this is
really uh very throw the whole
programming system gotcha thank you
in your example Q is prime but what if Q
is like 64. how do you represent the uh
the values of the field uh I mean q is
64 so then we are not talking about a
finite field then we have this kind of
the bit Vector reasoning so this would
be the second part of my talk and yeah
we had
there is a field I mean q is a prime
power in the Beautiful
uh
uh sent that so in the
in the table so as I already said uh so
then we have these intervals of the
possible values
and this is so we use sage
in our implementation Sage is dealing
with uh
I have one more question actually
um
um can you restart I mean it's just a
trail with a bunch of decisions
um and you have uh um you have reason
Clauses of why something happened you
can ostensibly keep land the recent
closes and just you know restart and
right and yeah different polarity speak
different variables yeah so in ffsat we
currently do not have this restarts but
um I think police that we do
talk uh move on not to the second part
um so where we now have the reasoning
um over the bit vectors and our tool is
not called the polysat
uh I will skip over some parts and we
already heard this week so kind of the
reason why we're interested in in that
is that the need that we want to reason
about large uh
um
speed Vector so for example 265 uh
um so why can't we like use our stuff
that I just showed you
and throw it now into polyester and the
reason is because we do not have a field
anymore because now we're talking about
the finite commutative ring so a lot of
the computations that work in a finite
field do not work for bit vectors one
case would be for example we cannot
conclude from X and Y greater than equal
to zero that x times Y is also greater
than x the reason is because now we have
this overflow constraints
or also kind of the uh now our field has
zero devices so from X Y both aren't
equal to zeric we cannot conclude that
the product is also not equal to zero
and also kind of the usual inequality
normalization so what you would do uh
from X small equal to Y you bring both
to one side
um this also fails but this have
actually an example
when we have for example X plus 3 is
small or equal to X Plus Y modulo 2 to
the power three
um if we would bring it to one side this
would give us then a constraint three uh
so equal to Y so then we get y should
can take the solution three four five
six seven
and
but if we for example have already X is
equal to two on the trail uh set then we
see that this constraint can only work
anymore for y is equal to three four
five so we really need to be careful uh
what we are doing
um yeah so far solving approaches for
bit vectors have been uh bit fasting or
in-pasting
um but the already has also been the
work on mcsat-based approaches and
polysat goes into Direction uh so we
have research really for assignment to
beat Vector variables
foreign
and
so we want to search for modeling these
input constraints by incrementally
assigning the speed uh variables and
this has been already asking the
question so we need to keep track of the
viable values uh and then also generate
this uh it's limits on demand
um
yeah so far these are kind of bit Vector
constraints that we align in police out
so we have the inequalities overflows
some bitwise constraint for example as a
bit wise end then uh shift and clauses
or this function of constraint literals
and Battery reduction we can generate a
bunch of other constraints like
equations inequalities bitwise negation
bitwise or and also talk about quotients
questions
um so the question is what's what's
actually this uh this Omega notation
says so here uh it's with the asterisks
this means that the multiplication
between p and Q can overflow so we
really say that we consider that this is
larger than 2 to the power of K so that
it kind of wraps around again
speeding up a little bit so as also in
police out this kind of this empty sat
based approach where we have to put in
values and we also assign intellectual
values to the big Vector variables
the same components I'm jumping over
this
example
um
the only thing that I want to mention
here is
um
that now we have different ways to to
talk about conflicts that we did not
have before so for example here now we
run into the the conflict uh with our
previous partial assignment 12 times y
plus 7 should be equal to zero and now
we have know that we have a conflict due
to the parity because there's not no
variable that we can decide to buy such
that
um
kind of constrained recovers
and so we can already at this point
conclude that we are unsatisfied
and the question was how to to choose
the values and so I will talk briefly
about how we represent now this value is
import
so for each variable we try to keep
track of of the variable values and from
all these variable values that we still
have we could choose a value for new
decision
in case our variable set is only a
single set with only one one choice left
then of course we can propagate that if
it's the empty set then we know we're
fixed the conflict
and whenever constraints become simple
enough then we reuse it to restrict our
viruset
and as already said currently our viable
set is represented as a set of intervals
and when a variable X appears only
linearly in a constraint then we extract
the so-called forbidden interval so we
keep track of the variables that we do
not are not allowed to take and add this
at constraint
um
in our knowledge base additionally since
we also have some some bitwise
constraints we keep track of some of the
fixed bits of X so that we can also can
reason about that for example talking
about like X it needs to be even or odd
and
the photo representation we use half
open intervals
and uh but wrap around if the the
smaller part is greater than the the
upper part so for example if we have an
interval between two and five then of
bit networks we cannot take values free
for a two three four
if we talk about like 13 to 2 then 13 14
15 and we wrap around and also exclude
one or zero if both are left the values
I have the same values and actually it's
empty interval and
we can add the informations about the
intervals as inequality constraints
um
into our knowledge base
um let me also jump over that
because what I want to show you is how
we actually kind of get to our forbidden
interval so what's actually the purpose
that we have so assume we have now
several
um
kind of several Clauses give us uh
information about The Forbidden interval
for the variable X
and with the partial assignment we get
done some concrete intervals
that will cover our domain so for
example assume that we have here a one
forbidden interval kind of the red
interval this tells us we shouldn't take
or we are not allowed to take a very
between those two parts
then we have a blue one that's a little
bit overlapping
and then also the third one the green
one
that's also overlapping and you see
what's happening now is that with
several intervals we've covered the
whole domain
and we encode that with symbolic
intervals and what this tells us then if
we have such a case then we've run into
a conflict and we need to backtrack
the question is now how do we get to
this polynomial to this forbidden
intervals from the inequalities
um we only do that when a certain
variable for which we want to extract
the interval becomes linearly
there are some easy cases for when the
the coefficients of uh the qualities can
only be zero and one but what we're
actually doing is we make that more
generous we talk about
um
when both so p and Q can take the same
values when they can be this equal
to generalize this extraction of the
Forbidden device
but I think I will
jump over that so how we actually do
this uh Define this uh for patient
intervals for it is quality coefficients
and yeah quickly tell you like this is
not our
Soul conflict resolution strategy that
we have with the Forbidden intervals
um so we have a bunch of other like
techniques that uh we use
so the uh to to uh
have detect and also resolve the
conflicts maybe we also do some kind of
superposition variable eliminations with
um I already talked in my first part uh
kind of when we know that we have a
bound uh on a variable then we do some
plant propagation on some other
variables
um yeah and so on and so forth and you
see here now this dot dot dot so this
dot dots is actually where we are
currently are so we're expressing try to
extract more of this conflict resolution
plugins to really uh be able to reason
about the benchmark
and with that I'm now
um at the end of my talk so thank you
very much
foreign
explanation plugins
um it's as if the beat Vector theory was
kind of a union of theories except it's
not really disjoint
um
like you have collaborations between
several explanation mechanisms that
interact within this mcsat mechanism
um have you ever thought of of seeing
bit vectors as uh
you know uh
a union of of some theories like bit
vectors seen as arithmetic things bit
vectors seen as you know bitwise
operations
um
okay okay
all right okay
and and uh so what one uh say say one
one issue we're struggling with here is
um that there's not uh say
a methodology for when are we done with
the limits
so it's very interesting
uh can you sort of
describe how far have you been able to
get past bit blasting at this point
it's not really also always did the bit
with the causes us the problems so for
some parts we really we are there yet
with the 265 bits but for some
constraints when you have a certain
shape then then we are still down yeah I
just wonder you know because
Factory reasoning has been kind of stuck
with bit blasting for a long time and
it's been hard to
to get past it I was wondering just how
far you feel like obviously it's a
qualitative answer but
okay you feel like you're getting I
think
I want to make one qualifying comment
which is so the motivation is a smart
contract we have 256 bits bit blasting
just doesn't work there's no way
um and uh so the current alternatives
are to translate to integer arithmetic
or some custom solver here and so in
these cases the either the integer
arithmetic or the custom solver can do
things that bit blasting has no chance
of ever achieving so and you can also
see it as some what reaction to should
uh bit Vector solving necessarily be
translated to set and then solved and I
think that's a losing proposition in the
long term
but but for 32-bit 64 bits
set works much better than
uh in slides you had uh like uh put a
variable ordering it's not a like
theoretical
restriction
to to to give assignments no that's not
a theoretically um our choice to do
that right so you fix in the beginning
and then yeah you stick with it yes okay
because in in yikes we have like uh to
mate's Point uh
um visits uh
uh to bump variable ordering and do
frequently starts it's like a SAT solver
uh behaves like that
hey
um in that case uh let's conclude uh
thank you Daniel for the talk
[Applause]
Maybe